thirst can kill and soak and hunger when
essential agriculture grows dry
at the beginning of the war in ukraine
russian forces destroyed a concrete dam
in southern ukraine ukrainians had built
the structure in 2014 after russia
illegally annexed crimea
at the time ukrainians wanted to block
the nipper river water that had flowed
to crimea since the soviet era and
diverted to the ukrainian city of curson
it's not clear if the current attack on
the dam was russia's way of settling a
score in those early days of its
unprovoked invasion of ukraine but it
did show how disrupting an enemy's
access to water can be an especially
vicious tactic of war and since water
makes food possible how it can be used
with devastating impact on civilians
human life is unimaginable without water
worldwide 2.2 billion people don't have
access to safe water which means that
they are more vulnerable to malnutrition
and death better water sanitation and
hygiene could prevent at least nine
percent of global disease and six
percent of global deaths according to
the centers for disease control and
prevention conflict is a major driver of
insecure access to clean and safe water
water can be a source of conflict and at
the same time a resource that becomes
scarcer in conflict there have been a
number of instances around the world
this year where military action has
destroyed water supply
that's according to the water focused
think tank the pacific institute like
the dam destruction in ukraine there was
an airstrike that hit water tanks in
yemen and an assault by the insurgent
group al-shabab on water supply in
somalia which killed 10 soldiers and
injured 15. in mali attacks on villages
took out water infrastructure and killed
four and in palestine the israeli
military destroyed agricultural
facilities that included a water tank in
syria a country already suffering
through years of war and drought russian
warplanes wrecked a water station and
also wounded a worker
because humans need water to survive it
has been used as a weapon of war and
because ukraine is today known as
europe's breadbasket a global hunger
catastrophe could come as war threatens
the country's harvest of staples like
wheat and sunflower oil north africa and
the middle east are especially
vulnerable because they're big customers
of ukrainian agriculture
water of course has a lot to do with all
of that farming
since 2020 the pacific institute has
tracked more than 200 instances of
water-related conflict compared to 629
total in the entire decade prior
they say it's only a matter of time
before climate change pushes even more
tension to the surface
eventually conflicts over water could
occur in america too
[Music]
you